[Musique]
et on
qu'il paraît
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'on sauve amiens
comme la route ou obsolètes comme quand
le corps se laisse aller l'océan et moi
je manie tragi
être mon ami je pas superstitieux mais
tes chansons mari
ma fille m'a saoulé pour cacher son
rouge à lèvres écoute moi bien beaucoup
écouté à brahim à chaque fois tombées
des murs qu'est ce qu'il ya de spécial
thon rouge à lèvres normes accroche toi
bien bruyant le prix de ma jambe le
machin pourquoi ce cas une rose dans une
fac tu arrives là tu en fais quoi de la
route tu t'appliques dans le derche
[Musique]
vous
ressemblez jam était celui d'un livre a
tellement fort qu a pris on va prier
devenir la même personne
à temps
c
[Musique]
yu
là
[Musique]
à